good morning john this christmas i
wanted to share something with you
something that i love
it's a book by aaron kubo that i saw as
a twitter thread 12 months ago and i
loved it so much
i wanted to turn it into a video so join
me
for a reading of the christmas creature
gather my children this winter night the
air is crisp
and the stars are bright turn off the
tunes
and take a pause cease your thoughts of
santa claus
and hark the season's vital feature
appeasing the great christmas creature
his trials are strange and tricky too
but heed my words
and you'll make it through the first
test would be the christmas
boy he'll knock and ask for your
favorite toy
hand it over and hold back your tears
you'll get it back
so have no fear the second test
is the asking bird you must tell the
truth
with every word the christmas creature
can hear your lies
and watch you through your own dog's
eyes
the third test comes on christmas
morning when you receive
your christmas warning and yes
you are allowed to share call up your
friends and compare
after that you'll know it's time to make
your dreaded christmas
climb when you hear a high-pitched
shriek most shrill
coming from your hometown's highest hill
so grab your offerings real quick a lock
of hair
a real good stick if you've been naughty
a pint of blood
a haunted chalice a mound of mud he'll
judge your gifts
so beware use a bow and wrap with care
climb the hill and as you get nearer
take out your special christmas
mirror you mustn't look directly at his
face
or your memories will be replaced walk
backwards to him
and throw your gift into the yawning
blue not
red rift toss it true
and toss it quick before the fog around
you gets too thick
now the christmas creature will ruminate
on your special christmas fate and if
you've done
everything just right now bong bing bong
will ring
through the night the christmas
creature's great eyes will glow
your stolen toy will appear in the snow
mostly the same
but a little wet and now
you're in the creature's debt it's
tradition
so don't be scared and merry christmas
you've been spared
aesthetic is weird like i would have to
look really hard and for a long time to
have a good idea of why
i love that story so much like i see a
lot of stuff on twitter and
rarely do i reach out to the person who
made this stuff and
say like i would like to license that
for a video and then i'm going to get my
friend sam to animate it and i'm gonna
license some music for it and record
narration for like two hours
to get two minutes of performance i i
don't know
i also don't know why i spent like 10
hours over the last few weeks working on
my piece of the unofficial tick-tock
ratatouille musical but one thing
we should know about this is that taste
is not like
universally good or bad that's our
values and our world views and our
experiences and our ideologies like the
vlogbrothers project for awesome 2021
calendar available now designed by megan
tennis like
why do i love it so much i think it goes
a long way down
i think it's a good idea to examine our
aesthetics but i also think it's a good
idea
to indulge in our aesthetics and thus
christmas creature and ratatouille
musical and
project for awesome calendar and these
freaking socks aaron kubo is selling
physical copies of the christmas
creature on her website you can get
those at the link in the description
same with the calendars in the socks
the ratatouille musical is not for sale
john i'll see you on tuesday